we aren't graphing why that's a really
bad wife sorry why it's slightly better
for graphing y against verses X so you
can pretend that this middle road
doesn't exist I'm not worrying about
this data at all I'm just looking at
these two and these two and these two
and these two is that okay so my
coordinates are going to be I might
write them down what's the first set of
coordinates that I get from the first
two column zero zero zero zero I'm
looking at X&Y what about these ones I'm
gonna get one and two then it goes to
two and and lastly three and yeah okay
so it's important that we note these
values to begin with because that
defines our scale right so pick a nice
round number that's big enough to
capture all of these 60 60 works for me
okay so on our vertical scale because
these are Y values I'm gonna go up to 60
horizontal scale is fine to go up to
three okay so let's put in well I mean
yes but daughter is like that you know
age versus the number of grams I weigh
like oh you know you just life has
numbers that don't match up nicely I
guess what we would call this is a
problem about magnitude but that's okay
our graph constrain can squash and do
whatever so I'm going to mark a top spot
in there and call that 60 I guess I'll
go 40 and 20 and between Noir and 20 I
think I probably want 10 as well okay is
that all right horizontally I'm going to
go zero one two three one two three and
now I'm ready to plot so my first one is
the origin so that's convenient I'm just
gonna put a big fat dot there my next
one is 1 comma 2 so I go across all the
way to 1 2 is going to be very very
close to the axis someone
get in there there we go okay so on my
scale it almost doesn't even get off the
axis but it's just there two comma 16 so
I pitch it around there and my last one
is 3 comma 54 so just skyrockets okay so
3 like so all right now we've plotted
the points the last thing we need to do
is join them all up together and you can
see you can visualize that smooth curve
that joins them all up nicely so let's
try it the best we can I'm pretty happy
with that
there we go that's alright that's why
we're graphing I was going to say that's
why we got from pencil but never mind
graphing in pencil is definitely the way
to go
graphing in any reasonable erasable
substance is the table okay that's a
really good question and the answer my
response to like aren't they going to
scan it is draw it in pencil first to
get the shape and then go over impending
I highly advise that you do
um I can't answer that question because
I don't know what happens in our
scanning process it's like black box
that I can't say I can tell you this I
can't tell you this people get pencil
scanned and some of it comes through
like it's not like this the pencil it's
invisible ink you know I'm so they'll
see something but especially when it
comes to a graph they don't know how
much yeah exactly if you you know if
your the pencils not very clear so
that's why we say to be safe okay graph
y versus x done that's it okay but when
we go to the next part we're going to
draw a new set of axes and the axes are
going to be labeled completely
differently it says y versus X to the N
they say n because in this question that
n changes right so in this case it'll be
X to the 3 so here's a y-axis and here's
an x cubed axis you remember last time
we had a square root of W axis you can
have an X cubed axis you can have any
axis you like so now remember how in the
first one we ignored this middle row
so now which row am I going to ignore
the top one it doesn't exist anymore
it's persona non-grata I'm just gonna
look at these guys okay so just like
before I'm gonna write down these
coordinates so I still start at the
origin and then what's next 1 comma 2
what's next 8 16 and then the last one
is okay I've got all of my points just
like before I'm gonna have a look and
think what would be nice values that
would give me the hole that would fit
all of the points I'm supposed to graph
I think 1630s perfect okay so my
vertical scale doesn't change why is
that by the way why hasn't it changed
yeah I'm still graphing against Y right
so that's stay put so I'm gonna go to 60
and 40 and 20 and just like before it
will be useful for me to include 10 but
my horizontal axis is changed because
well the horizontal axis is not an X ax
anymore it's an X cubed axis you taught
me to go up to 30 so I'm going to do
that for the same reason as before I'm
going to put five there as well be Haney
what's the first point that's okay you
guys are still drawing that's fine um
the first point on my list out of 4 is 0
0 the origin so I'll put my fat dot
there 1 Conner - now we went all the way
up to 30 so this is going to be very
very close to the origin but do the best
you can I'm gonna put mine around there
ok and then it starts to grow much
quicker 8 comma 16 8 comma 16 so it's
not all the way to 10 it's not all the
way to 20 it's something like maybe that
yeah and my last one is 27:54 so 27 is
quite close to 30
okay now I'm hoping you guys will have
done a slightly better job at this than
I have you have the advantage of a ruler
and you also have the advantage of a
grid what you should find is your one
two three four dots are they all on a
straight line can you join them up with
the ruler hopefully yes debatable
mine just barely makes it I had to make
it sort of a line of best fit but I got
there okay so look at the very first
example we started with today when we
were looking at weight and energy
thank you very much a keel I'll be
thanking you for this for the rest of my
life okay we turned a curvy graph into a
strict graph very very useful because
you can read it better we've done it
again we've turned this curvy graph into
this straight graph we just change the
axes that we were using make sense okay
okay the last question here part three
it's a bit wordy I'll give you a second
to read it yourself and digests very
similar yeah very similar in fact Renee
it's actually question two and question
one because they asked us to determine
and then they asked us to write an
equation so let's do it together
determine which variables vary directly
that's the first piece okay have a look
look at the graphs it's clearly this one
this is the direct variation that's how
you know it's a straight line so the two
quantities I'm looking at are Y and X
cubed so I'm gonna write Y varies
directly is proportional to X cubed okay
but then they want more than this this
is not an equation it's a relationship
but it's not an equals so I'm gonna go y
equals and what's the name we usually
put for that constant it's okay
yeah it sort of turns into it's like oh
no muscle memory anyway
now at this point we were having a look
at what we're looking at on diameter and
arm Lee thank I think so I did something
to this to find out what K was what did
I do I solve for K and the where did
that was I replace these guys do you
remember we took some measurements okay
now these guys have taken the
measurements for us you see what I mean
they're provided all the information now
you actually have loads to choose from
you have those situational but you have
to be careful for instance I can tell
you and you can tell me why this is a
piece of data that is true but useless
because what happens when I put it in
you get you get 0 equals K times zero
which is true but not helpful doesn't
get me any close to them okay all right
so I can print pick pretty much any
other one that you just have to see
clear Oh what happens if I do this one
okay let's put them in which one is
which one is X so K times 1 cubed and
that makes this one - yeah well 1 cubed
is just 1 so that means that K is equal
to 2 that's not the variation equation
that's just K which goes into the
variation equation so I'm going to go y
equals and there is the variation
variation equation they actually want ok
in fact what you've done is you've given
this graph over here you see this do you
remember oh this is what cubic graphs
look like you could do the other side it
looks like like that bit right so you
have used the data to determine what
that equation was ok